le hollandais à plusieurs bonnes raisons
de surveiller ses digues le matin le
soir et la nuit
mais parmi toutes ces bonnes raisons les
meilleurs et blonde et rose
il a des enfants qui jouent au dessous
du niveau de la mer la veille et
comptines et tout ce qui peut fixer le
remblai protégé à son tour par les
fonctionnaires du ministère des eaux qui
ont l'oeil à tout et sur toute chose les
enfants l'horizon et cet animal
d'apocalypse qu'ailleurs on juge
inoffensif et qu'on appelle un lapin le
lapin fait des trous et dans ce pays un
trophée est une invitation au déluge de
l'autre côté on voit la mer mais la
grande idée qui était la hollande ce que
la lutte contre la maison d'autriche
sous le retour de les esses lorraine a
été à la france c'est l'assèchement du
devis d'erezée de cet immense poche
d'eau sel et que paul claudel comparer
un poumon
aspirant l'air du large pour régénérer
le système circulatoire des fleuves et
des canaux reprendra la mer les terres
englouti ajouter une province aux
provinces unies fermer la couronne
ébréché de ce côté en raccourcissant
littoral de plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres
telle est depuis des siècles la pensée
constante des administrateurs le sujet
de concours d imagination et le thème
récurrent des conflits parlement très
davantage qui pendant qu'un pays riches
dutronc de la réalisation de ce projet
sont des plus tôt une nouvelle li
fertile province viendra s'ajouter à
notre pays une grande partie de nos
pêcheries sacrifier l'assèchement du g20
sera grandement notre
déjà l'étranger la santé publique sera
menacée c'est de la plus grande
importance nationale et des grands
risques peuvent et doivent être pris
sans parler du risque de surproduction
ce projet à d'une absolue nécessité
comme d'habitude il fallut un
commencement de catastrophe pour clore
le débat
les inondations 1916 de nerfs gagnent
cause à l'ingénieur cornelis lille et au
grand savant lawrence à qui l'on fournit
un laboratoire d'hydraulique tout neuf
et ce thème de composition encourageant
comment avec un pied sur le continent et
l'autre dans l'eau fait reculer de 50
kilomètres l'une des mers les plus
violentes du globe pour lui soutirer
deux cent vingt mille hectares de
jardins potagers changer le restant lac
d'eau douce en régulateur de pression et
accessoirement pourquoi pas en ballon de
chauffage central en 1927 l'armée des
techniciens se déclarait prête
le ministre des finances aussi
l'offensive était déclenchée
en 1932 les mâchoires du zuiderzee
étaient soudés par une digue de 32
kilomètres de long et 2 80 m de large
la mère venait heurter à ce formidable
boulevard de l'autre côté duquel sont
nos invivable étaient peu à peu remplacé
par l'eau douce de la rivière hissel
embranchements collatérale du rhin
simultanément une digue circulaire mais
tel fond de la mer à sec au nord ouest à
l'emplacement choisi pour le 1er pôle
d'air de l'ex-leader the ringer mer 20
mille hectares de terres nouvelles
engraissés dans la mer pendant des
siècles qu'ils n'étaient plus que les
décès les parts de persévérance
d'injection d'eau douce ainsi naissait
l'une de ses peintures abstraites que
les polders nous met sous les yeux avec
leurs échantillons de couleurs disposées
entravé rectiligne leurs villages
modèles et leur petite fille qui ne le
sont pas moins
lancé à bicyclette dans le sillage des
caravelles
en 1942
tandis que l'armée d'occupation nazie se
préparer à couvrir sa retraite en
ajoutant qu'une inondation ou catalogue
de ces désastres un deuxième pôle d'air
se former au nord-est par le même
procédé digues circulaires assèchement
traitement à l'eau douce résultats
cinquante-huit mille hectares aussitôt
mise en exploitation quadrillé de route
et cadeaux sous le filet des lignes
électriques à haute et basse tension la
méthode artisanale pourtant gardé adepte
des fermiers à mentalité capétienne
agrandissent leur pré carré à l'âme en
allant chercher de l'autre côté de l'eau
censée monte au dessus du niveau de la
mer de longue bande de terre qu'ils
ramènent chez eux à la gaffe et à la
rame pour l'adjoindre protéger familiale
et ajouter quelques centimètres au
territoire national
dans ces conditions comment tenir un
cadastre
après la guerre un troisième et un
quatrième pole day reviendront compléter
l'aménagement du jury des rg qui perd
son nom et devient la glisse est
l'ingénieur cornelis lez lille donnera
le sien la capitale de la nouvelle
province sortis de son imagination
créatrice des milliers de kilomètres de
drains seront posées qui seront comme
les tuyaux d'orgue sur lesquels
l'hydraulique et jouera les mouvements
compliqués de la symphonie des réseaux
les techniques du béton viendront donner
aux digues nouvelle les assises
indestructible qui manquait aux
anciennes on travaillera ainsi jours par
semaine
et 7e on se reposera en faisant mémoire
du célèbre passage l'écriture sainte qui
commence par ces mots dieu dit qu'il y
est une étendue entre les eaux et
qu'elle sépare les autres avec les eaux
que les eaux qui sont au dessus du ciel
se rassemble en un seul lieu et que le
sec par s et il en fut tass
mais quelle guerre jamais fini quelle
guerre et jamais gagné le 1er février
1950 trop l'une des plus violentes
tempêtes de l'histoire on paie les 10
les plus anciennes et dissolvait les
dunes comme autant de châteaux de ça
mais lui 100 personnes périrent des
animaux par milliers le hollandais
regardez sa terre une fois encore qu'ils
fuyaient sous ses pas
cent cinquante mille hectares de terre
avait disparu
et par les brèches ouvertes aux
dispositifs de défense
la marée avait repris son énorme
respiration infligeant deux fois par
jour aux équipes de réparateurs des
différences de niveaux atteignant
parfois 4 m la solution c'est le dernier
conflit mondial qu'il a fournis sous la
forme des gigantesques caisson en béton
long de 63 mètres large de 18
au de 19 mètres et pesant 7 mille tonnes
construisent en angleterre pour monter
les jeter du débarquement en normandie
il n'y avait plus qu'à les encastrer
dans les brèches
les difficultés de l'opération ayant été
minutieusement reconstitué en
laboratoire on passe à la théorie à la
pratique
les réserves du débarquement ne
suffisant pas on construisit en quelques
mois des centaines d'éléments en béton
qui fut rassemblée sur place après une
lutte épuisant la dernière trou et fut
fermée le 6 novembre de la même année
mais les hollandais qui ne veulent pas
revoir les images qui ont défilé sous
nos yeux tout à l'heure ont entrepris de
fermer les quatre grands bras de mer qui
isole encore les terres du sud ouest
c'est le plan delta qu'il a déjà reçus
un large commencement d'exécution de
nombreux barrages ont été construits des
digues élevé des routes tracées de
nouveaux espaces dégagés au site occupé
par la population la plus dense et la
plus jeune aussi du monde entier
les travaux du plan delta seront achevés
en 1978
ce sera ensuite le tour des îles du nord
quand ce sera fait et frontières
maritimes de la hollande opposera à la
mer la ligne d'un retranchements
pacifique ininterrompue du nord au sud
ce sera fini non le combat lui
hollandais pour assurer la stabilité de
son pays à géométrie variable ne finira
jamais il le sait dès l'aube ils montent
en ligne telle est sa condition sa joie
c'est cette terre mouillée qui semble
suspendue entre le ciel et l'eau qui
frémit encore et qui est l'oeuvre de ses
mains
ou pas